[Musique]
alors leur wii comme de mulhouse est un
club d'aviron qui a été créée en 1893
qui vient de fêter ses 125 ans cette
année et qui vit toujours qui est
actuellement 200 membres et ses 200
membres pratiquent très régulièrement
l'aviron on a un très grand garage à
bateaux qui est ici sur le côté dans
lequel on a des bateaux pour faire ramer
à peu près 120 personnes en même temps
donc il ya deux ans à peu près on a
décidé au niveau du comité du club de
créer une section handisport et de
développer dans un premier temps
l'aviron à destination de rameurs
déficients visuels et donc cette section
existe aujourd'hui et les fortes au bout
d'un an et quelques mois en plus de
s'être membres qui pratiquent très
régulièrement l'avion aussi bien sûr
look en salles dans la suite de nos
activités nous avons comme projet de
développer l'aviron a destinateur des
rameurs paraplégique nous avons donc
déjà investi dans du matériel nous avons
deux bateaux qui sont déjà au club
propriété du club et nous sommes en
contact avec le président du conseil
départemental de la fédération
handisport pour effectivement commencé à
faire connaître cette activité faire
découvrir ce sport
nos premiers membres alors bien entendu
avant de lancer toutes ses activités
nous avons effectué toutes les
formations nécessaires aujourd'hui le
club d'aviron de mulhouse est labellisé
aviron indoor ce qui permet la pratique
en salle labellisé avis fit ce qui nous
permet une pratique de notre sport sous
une forme un peu fitness très très
dynamique destination de membres qui ne
souhaitent pas forcément aller sur l'eau
nous sommes également labellisé aviron
santé et aviron handicap
donc ces formations ont été effectués
dans les deux dernières années ont été
financées par le conseil départemental
en partie en grande partie est
aujourd'hui cela nous permet de mettre
en place ces différentes actions
or les formations aviron handicap
recoupent différents axes nous avons
effectivement nous travaillons avec des
personnes atteintes de déficience
visuelle
mais nous avons donc aussi pour objet
d'intervenir sur le handicap physique à
travers des rameurs plaire paraplégique
nous pouvons et nous accueillons
ponctuellement intervenir sur des
déficiences intellectuelles ou des
déficiences mentales
nous avons déjà accueilli plusieurs
groupes de trisomiques et d' autiste et
ses différentes actions nécessitent tout
de même une adaptation du matériel en
salle nous avons été obligés d'investir
dans des ergomètres des machine à ramer
un peu spécifiques qui permettent
d'accueillir ce public en ce qui
concerne l'aviron à destination des
paraplégiques les bateaux sont standards
mais nécessite un équipement
complémentaire très particulier sont
équipées de sièges fixes avec des
sangles de flotteurs de sécurité et dans
le cas de l'aviron santé qui rejoint
certains problèmes que nous avons aussi
sur l'avion handicap nous avons des
bateaux embarquement profond c'est comme
ça qu'on les appelle qui là ne nécessite
pas d'adaptation est carrément d'acheter
un matériel neuf qui permet ce type
d'embarquement pour des personnes
souffrant d'arthrite de surpoids ou de
faiblesse musculaire
alors toutes ces actions sont lancés
sont mises en place les investissements
matériels sont réalisés aujourd'hui nous
sommes en contact avec différentes
associations pour le public pour
accueillir ce type de public et nous
vous invitons donc tous à venir nous
rejoindre pour découvrir ces types de
pratiques un peu différent mais qui
reste toujours fondamentalement l'aviron
[Musique]